j'ai été observatrice de la coop 21 au
titre des nations unies pour le groupe
d'experts sur l'évolution du climat
donc j'ai observé tout ce travail
délicat de négociations avec les
représentants des différents
gouvernements
il y avait également beaucoup d' espace
de dialogue entre les chercheurs la
société civile le monde de l'entreprise
les organisations non gouvernementales
les représentants des différents pays
sur un certain nombre de sujets parce
que c'est aussi une occasion pour
transmettre nos connaissances vers le
monde politique où l'ensemble de la
société
donc au tour de l'université paris
saclay il ya beaucoup d'acteurs
scientifique des recherches portant sur
les causes du changement climatique sur
les scénarios d'évolution possible futur
et aussi sur les impacts du changement
climatique que ce soit sur les sociétés
humaines ou sur certains écosystèmes
on se structure avec la mise en place de
cette université dans le cadre en
particulier d'un département des
sciences de la planète et de l'univers
afin de répondre aux enjeux énergétiques
et climatiques qui ont été évoqués lors
de notamment lors de la cop 21 une
réponse opérationnelle et concrètes qui
est proposé dans le cadre de
l'aménagement du plateau de saclay et la
réalisation d'un réseau de chaleur et
2,3 à base d'énergie géothermique
l'échelle de l'infrastructure et des
besoins permet d'accéder à une ressource
locale inépuisable qui la nappe de
l'albien il s'agit donc d'un réseau de
chaleur et de froid à base d'énergie
géothermique
comment cela fonctionne il y à un forage
qui permet de puiser cette eau cette eau
circule dans un réseau géothermale est
ensuite réinjectée à nouveau dans la
nappe de l'albien veut dire qu'on est
sur un circuit fermé
la solution technique proposée par
l'industriel permet d'atteindre une
haute performance énergétique et
environnementale l'énergie livrée sera
62 % renouvelable et les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre seront trois fois
inférieur à une solution conventionnelle
fonctionnant au gaz la coop 21 ça a
vraiment été une réussite à la fois dans
son organisation et puis également dans
l'accord de paris donc c'est un accord
universel qui va être ouvert à
ratification mais qui a été approuvé par
les représentants des 195 pays qui
étaient présents c'est probablement
l'accord le plus ambitieux qui pouvaient
être obtenus au consensus de l'ensemble
des pays présents